down into a one-on-one good trades but
it's simple and he's already here right
outside smoke gonna go off simple on the
other side to pulls out the pistol he's
got the P 250 close range it's a
one-shot nitro he's got a triple he
fakes it once and just goes to check the
window this is all about timing
nitro does have a lot of another smoke
so it could be really rough for simple
tanks to get through this he's gotta
throw the guys to call dust to a staple
and counter-strike would be one hell of
an understatement
since its release in CS 1.1 it's become
perhaps the quintessential CS man and no
I didn't stutter dust2 is just about 18
years old now having been released in
March of 2001 in this video we'll be
taking a tour of all of dust2 s most
iconic spots and all of dust twos most
iconic moments will start at B site and
tons and we'll move on to mid and the
infamous double doors then we'll end up
at a site cap and long a and at the end
we'll take a trip down memory lane to CS
1.6 and source and look at some of the
best clips we could find from those eras
so let's start this video off like any
good pug and rush beat and if you guys
stop in tongues I promise and won't
block you in the back of the head this
time they have miscommunicated though it
looks I mean there is a smoke there but
Kris dry looking out towards mid here
comes the head yeah that's what - you
help them with a waltz and a great
coldest phrasing head shots in a row
unbelievable and that's gonna be over
time look at Oscar just laughing what
even happened well he'd better do
something crazy here because it's gonna
be a one on four he's got off in three
ak's finally shuts it down the bomb it's
being put down yes but how tough is he
gonna be for fnatic to actually keep
this bomb sign they heard the plant
happy tried to go aggressive trying to
rattle the shocks through but as you saw
MBK he's going full-on he's just ready
to pounce on through why would they slow
down there's the flash that's gonna
catch screams out they're gonna push on
through and BK gets Roberts brother's
rain looks to Holcomb busier doors
screams go throw his out as well towards
the same position no he's usually he
does get tacked down laptops and
relentless with his aggression
oh man two versus four against cannot
say there's so much time this is gonna
be almost impossible Nico hiding right
in the door in the smoke he's gonna try
and make his way through they haven't
seen him yet in this shooting the wrong
angle they turn their backs and he's got
the egg came and they're doing some time
to get crispy imma kill Nico now is the
time chris is gonna go down there in the
bomb site now and they're already on it
they need to get this through they gonna
have a kid so he's got a lot of times
work with you and you know on the
outside he gets the one til comes back
with noise Bray's
he wins one more this dog Nico he's
finished already cavity gets apart - oh
my god Nico just be going for a good old
B rush instead and he co actually
getting caught out oh don't even find
out where this players were that's how
you lookin to do work from with all
three flights three Tarek and I showed
on the jumping Slammy then it's Derek
with the bogey here the ice against the
North could be Russia
coming in and Stewie's the only one in
there and he's got an MP 9 he's gonna
get flat not be with a big split coming
on claiming it's the entry on the side
friggin down Edward and destroying the
hopes of Navi on this round and get it
over the ACE gets it they've got 40 to
help among three players full of free
incendiary he really needs to use that
as well one of them see him they didn't
see it when he came through he gets the
sprayed out of all three
that's ridiculous they're from Navi Zeus
down into a one-on-one good trades but
it's simple and he's already here right
outside smoke gonna go off simple on the
other side he pulls out the pistol he's
got the p250 close range it's a one-shot
nitro he's got a triple he fakes it once
and just goes to check the window this
is all about timing Nitro does have a
model have another smoke so it could be
really rough for several times to get
through this he's gotta throw so
obviously the B site has been the scene
for some of CS goes most legendary plays
but just wait till you see the
highlights waiting over at a so smoke
cross Wally goose cuz here's the best of
the a-site mom has dropped back in t
spawn nobody there to carry it in so fir
has to waste a little bit of time
actually right back here and well I mean
it works out if fall is gonna hit a sick
headshot like that on SWAT
fanatic in control of this round
fighting a lot more than they really eat
with it just wait until they get close
at the site avenge route gets the kill
Crim's gonna go down shroud showing up
it's now Jones winning it back unreal
[Music]
what spawns fine
where's fun kappa
[Music]
somebody can do though at this point now
I'm gonna be very very careful with that
Molly in place that flash hits him right
in the face and I was gonna push more
into the smoke the flanker coming up
behind him isn't gonna catch him now
he's looking for that to be a flash oh
holy crap let's see he's gotta find the
first one 14 seconds left on the clock
and he's gonna get hold back on the
Sisqo to win this round he's got his
hold back now he can't get too
aggressive though because if he pushes
this too heavily you can still take him
out he goes around a huge putt from very
lush resumes playing into smoke so if
fnatic choose to go big and try and cut
off a rotation if they choose to go a
you can make the split hard a spin to
allow Rubino to make his way in CT spawn
and see if you can punish elsewhere you
can see a player on platform toward a if
he looks over there
full-on sorry and indeed there it is
Tennessee going down and flusher has
decimated everyone but are picking up an
8a now looking to get his ace here the
flat coming in from the sea may become
big part already and there it is flush
up going to wreck the entire team here
crosses over sure but happy is there to
challenge happy fine saddest all
Janell 1v2 don't tell me you go passion
1v1 Kelly against Pasha the two players
who stepped up phenomenally for their
side it's gonna be going up against
Kenny s here one-on-one year with swag
swag full health still has an 8 if he
spots him and be able to blow up the
nade here no reason to peek he saw him
he's also gonna take the x-ray around a
down so we can build up the suspense
here all of you at home are probably
hating me right now oh this is all 5
members out here for witbox they have
nowhere to fall back to it's cool
he gets one killing it's absolutely
damaged through so Susie's very low
that's a second killer this is some
old-school scooter jumping up full
information a fourth kill and he could
get these that could stop Dexter that is
incredible
Garen Last Man Standing device that
draws speed East goes he's gonna go down
if that have been the old si said it
would have no issue at all get right
trying to walk and 1v2 running up here
p250 out jumping and shooting yes one
more kill looking for these got any
money down time is up oh my god are you
kidding me killing one second left now a
5 on 2 is JW picks up the 3rd kill and
they're gonna keep pushing here
Bailey's alive oh that's God's aww might
get much done leaving just exists alive
in a1 b3
exists as well not even really having a
good amount of Intel is to where exactly
should play these final C players
against doesn't spot the one below the
jump comes in get some good train image
back in but he himself is being pelted
outbreak weekly trainings out for a
clock but 27 HP exist doesn't have a
whole lot left to work with and also
constantly watching out for that plank
here now FNX he's gonna strike soon he's
out 12 8 be left on exist now with a
I'll start shuts it down exist might be
able to make there maybe could have got
to be just on the edge but this could be
smart or it could be over cold Sarah's
gonna get the beat now they know his
position 39 seconds he's 12 HP this is
so little to work with
okay okay this I think one's gonna hear
steps here but yeah here we go he's
gonna get up on out of this
this is incredibly intelligent from
exist making was a pretty bad situation
actually work from here you can plant
pretty safely they're gonna go fast
short retake so long as he keeps his
head down he's got a chance in this one
now now trying to hold back however as
the both of the ring members about
you're gonna try to go for a retake back
so right through County smoking he's in
the corner
that Cajun taking a fight aunt long
gonna hit the leg shot there on flusher
and has to immediately fall back reject
matters he's picking up behind the lines
he's gonna get the kill on siblings mom
is gonna go down this one be good always
play for now and for nine house got a
Molotov as well smoke goes down he's on
the other side of it it make something
of this you know they're all three
players feel lots of money in dose that
there still be able to afford whatever
will last your honor this is gonna be
really crucial know what happened but
it's a one on three fantastic play the
entry Fragger at his best
it looks like this is the beginning of
the end this could be the longest out
how long is this a lost cost for an IP
is not going to happen c-max are about
to 1611 MIP and sent them home before
the playoffs they have gone out of
groups this is anand doable situation
east team x actually managed to fail
this is gonna be a big mistake because
it's for a long plant three guys on long
let's see bow down though they're gonna
go in here goes with an abuse he has to
get it right now if not then they
the savior of Sweden I think me ready
for skadoodle here has the angle at the
end repeat of all top forcing anyone
away from swinging wide perhaps a set to
kill
granite third one skadoodle water
recovery at all all four kills for
skadoodle he shuts everything down from
liquid triple kill for fallen who has
been carrying his team he is the captain
here and he has been for a very long
time otherwise valium pasher kind of
loaded it will make this happen pasha
goes down as he gets found they got
three people in this bomb site waiting
and finally but he could have shot early
on dropsy coming in with a really good
timing gets a great doublet quad killed
just like that all of them headshots and
it's gonna be me alone here one on one
the bomb has dropped down there 40
seconds left and neo he knows that he's
just waiting for it this is gonna be a
real duel between the two legends neo
all he has to do is wait exactly and you
can see him adjusting his position right
here he's making up for the fact if if
shocks he chose to wrap around in
through mid doors neil would then have
that angle covered
and now neil worried about listening for
steps would be that's not gonna be the
case though shocks he manages the
dartboard he picks up football or you
kidding me socks he makes it out of
there do lets it happen
the edge is completely insane so execute
Zone B and retakes on a are one thing
but it's at mid where the wheat is
really separated from the chaff but the
cream raised all year and sometimes we
need inhuman reactions just to survive
he
is gonna go for it a Freiburg will
eventually fall but it is too late
Garen is gonna be waiting he co charges
in doesn't check reactions 3 B 1 what a
short day that was lovely shot from
flamey though he will manage to connect
looking for the second gets it and drops
the bomb he's got to be careful though
the mid push from the freeze why ready
flaming been working through 4k all
headshots oh they're coming around this
corner here but the thing is he does
they don't have armor he could chew them
up right here not checking the first one
yet right letting them through there the
watch off goes with a triple hit the
last man standing here jumping Pete's 50
panic must be done
if you can get sake killed after Baba's
walk and now you've got position here
dropping comes Kenny s oh my god Kenny s
with three insane kills and he has time
boy Philippines gonna win the round has
he got time yeah he's got home
unbelievable
so he does just trade evenly and I think
that's not good and I think he had to
get a couple of kills or he have to stay
alive but he couldn't really hide after
that first one for is wild flash gonna
take down civics what a big kill and
he's got to cease at out goes for more
takes to free he's ready with the opioid
nice device she's gonna get cut erdan
unfortunately not to buy back now oh my
god what do a wig what of what a
ridiculous sport almost bored but isn't
we're gonna be pronax onto the farm stat
till JW with metal awp but he's gay I'm
sure they've been boosted up going for
the aggressive pick and actually goes
all the way towards suicide and gets a
huge hedge on the Kerrigan that what a
massive pick that was its day to be
people are as well they've got to try
and compensate for giving like with so
much room in time to unleash that
accuracy is so good that my sensitivity
makes it look so easy as he flashes over
animal right now as betting will fall
trying to
back into the catwalk position he
stepped up in Cologne and he's doing
John maybe one honesty has to get on the
board they need to stop this whole
matter they cannot get bogged down at
rounds in this kind of a setting
especially because the CT side is their
better side it's their t side where they
really struggle it's time it's time for
counter strike again I don't get too
attached to it oh my god okay alright
then god jwe see sir oh my god what's
going on they're all dead what just
happened what what is happened but
please replay everything well guys so
far we've covered just about every inch
of dust - but there are plenty more
amazing plays waiting in cs:go storied
history so get ready for some sweet four
by three aspect ratios as we look at
some of the best plays from one point
six and source
[Music]
there's now two before dragons in big
trouble the frac masters looking strong
one before now scream is a big job on
his head he gets one on to it said he
gets another one that's three screens
standing away needle doesn't get the
diffuse
[Music]
and TW now two men down she's gonna come
in Nikko is watching there he actually
takes out two it's now all unfunny
[Music]
second one gets the third one dude this
is what amazing from Sonic not for from
Sonic one more remaining one absolutely
amazing amount from Sonic
well guys that's best up for this week
now if you do want more content just
like this I am a couple suggestions for
you rush that sub button like it's the B
site on a pistol round hit that like
button with your up like he peaked you
from mid doors and executed on the
comments section planting your comment
form I'll see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]